I'm very confident a hundred years from
now we won't have an FCC hi I'm Nick
Gillespie for recent TV and today we're
talking with Tom Haslett he's a longtime
Reason contributor he's a professor of
law and economics at George Mason
University and we're talking about net
neutrality Tom thanks for talking with
us
let's talk about net neutrality you
wrote recently a encounter books
broadside of a net neutrality we
reasoned write a lot about net
neutrality we tend to be against it and
we always have trouble actually defining
it we're just against it anyway what
isn't that neutrality and why is it
something that is problematic the way
that it's being discussed in the policy
or NATO network neutrality is a set of
rules which by the way are difficult to
define but they generally have to do
with regulating the business model that
your local ISP uses so you have an
Internet service provider it might be
Verizon or Comcast earth length there's
some other ones and they give you a
connection to the Internet the idea of
net neutrality is that they should only
provide you a connection to the Internet
now there may be some other things that
they do they might give you some
ancillary services for example your
cable company might give you telephone
service as well but they should keep
that separate and they should use their
internet connection as though it were an
open highway that any company could use
including themselves to provide those
other services and and now I be in the
way that this typically gets talked
about is you say somebody like Comcast's
which also provides content or creates
content it you know you get a Comcast
connection they're going to allow
Comcast material to get to you quicker
or they might even block stuff say from
Time Warner or a competitor why you know
why shouldn't we say now you know or why
shouldn't the law say no Comcast should
have you know they should just be
letting us plug in and get whatever we
want when we want because the government
has no idea what the optimal business
model is and well last night I went on
to see a baseball game and I was on ESPN
and they said watch here so I clicked on
and then it turns out that it said you
have to have one of these four internet
providers to be
to get the content okay so in that case
its ESPN which is not an Internet
service provider they the content
provider and they sell their content not
directly to me the customer but to the
ISP and they want those deals that's
that's where the content wants to go the
irony of the net neutrality policy is
it's advocated as though it's protecting
all the folks on the edge of the network
like the content and application
providers who aren't the transport
infrastructure like the ISPs and that
they're protecting to get into the
market but that's not true
that is it's it's a story but it turns
out not to be relevant to the actual
facts of the world how many instances do
we have that are documented where
Comcast or Time Warner or Verizon it's
actually throttling problem if you
actually read the the regulations the
FCC put into place in the end of 2010
they don't have actual evidence that
this is happening they claimed to they
have a couple of scare stories there was
a complaint lodged against one of these
mega corporations is that dominating the
broadband market who you know would that
be Comcast or Verizon or Time Warner
Cable it was metro pcs and what did they
do that was egregious and
anti-competitive well they have a couple
of different levels of service and their
older service they allow customers to
get all they want for voice texting and
data but because it's an older and
fairly slow system they can't do video
streaming in fact video streaming is
blocked so the network doesn't clog they
actually knew that video would be a
little bit of a problem because YouTube
is so damn popular so they went to
Google owner of YouTube and said look is
there any way you can compress your
signals so that we can actually make
this work on our old what they call it
two and a half G Network and Google said
sure we're we're the smartest people on
the planet we'll fix that and they came
back to them said here use this
compression technique and you know get
crazy for that they're violating
neutrality okay so that that runs
frontally into exactly the argument that
many economists have made that you want
the market to compete
and invent business models you don't
want the government to mandate some kind
of a platform when they don't know what
the really the efficient configure so
reason interviewed Michael Powell pushes
FCC Commissioner years ago and one of
the things that he said was you know it
just doesn't make sense to have print
media and or and cable media or certain
and Internet media being fully afforded
protections under the First Amendment
and broadcast content in a different
regime and that at some point these have
to merge because people do not access
their content in in the same way that
they're being regulated and he felt that
one in the future there would be one
standard and it would either be the
First Amendment or it would be a kind of
namby-pamby government regulation of
content is that is he right about that
and are you confident that the First
Amendment would win that battle yes and
I think in a hundred years from now I'm
very confident a hundred years from now
we won't have an FCC okay and the
question is you know how much sooner
than a hundred years can we make this
happen and I would say is you know with
respect to Michael Powell I mean it
that's an interesting the reason would
would interview him Powell is a great
example that Powell is a very bright guy
and he sees a lot of what a chairman of
the FCC should see I mean he's
perceptive but it's it's the structure
he was not able to move the the
Commission forward in most of the areas
that count we will need to talk within a
hundred years from now when the FCC no
longer exists I hope that the United
States does but you know that's a
crapshoot to put it on my Google
Calendar I want to thank Tom Haslett of
George Mason University law and
economics professor for talking with
Reason TV thanks very much I'm Nicholas
P
you